after weeks of speculation philippine
president rodrigo duterte has through a
representative filed his candidacy for
senator
the move comes after he publicly rebuked
his own daughter davao city mayor sarah
duterte for running as vice president
and running mate of the son of the late
dictator ferdinand marcus ferdinand
marcus jr
the older duterte says his daughter is
far more popular than marcus and that
the marcuses can never be trusted
especially when it comes to politics
that's a surprise to many because the
marcuses have been allies of the
dutertes since 2016.
for months now the dutertes have
repeatedly said they were not interested
in seeking higher office that's changed
in the past couple of days
so you can see how
they treat philippine politics it's like
a game and you know what shows also is
their very strong sense of entitlement
we've seen how the substitution works
we've seen how
personalities or people we do not know
filed candidacies for president vice
president senator only to withdraw and
then only to be place holders and give
way to personalities
while this may seem a typical jostle for
political power it is critical for
duterte's administration to remain in
control beyond 2022 president duterte is
facing investigations before the
criminal court for crimes against
humanity in his so-called war on drugs
which has left thousands of filipinos
dead
he and his allies are also expected to
face multiple cases for alleged
involvement in several corruption
scandals
critics say the administration may be
preoccupied with its own political
survival but much more is at stake for
the rest of the country next year
the next administration will inherit
unprecedented challenges the country is
still reeling from the impact of the
corona pandemic there is an ever
increasing national debt and growing
military tensions in the south china sea
even for a country with a long history
of upheaval during elections this is
unprecedented the 2022 elections will
not just be a battle between opposing
political parties but a fight between
powerful political dynasties jamal
alindogan al jazeera manila